finir au parc des princes il y avait un
autre match très important
paris saint germain a confirmé ses
ambitions puisque le psg a battu
marseille 2 1 regardez les buts de cette
rencontre 11e minute de jeu première
mi-temps ligne d'europe lance didier six
qui ouvre la marque à marseille un paris
saint germain 0 à la mi temps marseille
aura conservé toujours ce but davantage
malgré de très bonnes offensives du
paris saint germain 2e mi temps notre
action de la première mi temps encore
justement pour démontrer la bonne
qualité des attaques parisiennes avec
ses superbes retourné de mustapha dahleb
qui a bien failli trouver sa
concrétisation deuxième mi temps là avec
le but égalisateur du paris
saint-germain marquée par la nouvelle
vedette du paris saint-germain le
défenseur brésilien à bell dix minutes
plus tard le paris saint germain qui
domine toujours va réussir à marquer un
deuxième but après ce premier tir de
batna est repoussé par migeon bathenay
encore lee marque de la tête le deuxième
but le but de la victoire devant 45000
spectateurs enthousiastes un parc des
princes qui a vraiment eu le droit à un
grand match de football hier soir pour
son premier match de la saison